فايز الدويري الخدير العسكري والاستراتيجي
مرحبا بك سيد فايز يعني منذ صباح وحتى
الان تبقى المعلومات متضاربه بشان نقاط
السيطره لكل طرف خصوصا داخل العاصمه
باعتبار انها
العاصمه المركزيه
والسيطره عليها عمليا تعني انتصارا
بالمعنى العسكري لكن كيف تفسر هذا التضارب
وعدم وضوح الرؤيه عسكريا للواقع في
الخرطوم
يعني الواقع البيانات التي تصدر من طرفي
الصراع هي مبالغ فيها لانها مباشره تواجه
بنفي مضاد وبتصريح مضاد يعني السيطره على
مروي يقابلها اغلاق مداخل الخرطوم
الجنوبيه السيطره على قاعده في الاوبيض
يقابلها حديث عن مدينه اخرى اذا دعنا نقول
لا يوجد بيانات
نستطيع ان نخضعها للتحليل المنهجي المعمق
لا تزال الامور متضاربه ولكن من خلال
مقارنه القوى التي تم عرضها يفترض يفترض
بناء على
لغه الاعداد والارقام ام يتمكن الجيش من
حسم الامور لصالحه طالت فتره الصراع ام
قصرت لكن هناك نقطه اساسيه
تتمتع بها قوات الدعم وهي رغم
عدم وضوح
تسليحها بصوره دقيقه لكنها تعتمد على
الاسلحه الخفيفه والمتوسطه وبعض الثقيله
وعلى اليات الدفع الرباعي وبالتالي اليه
طبيعه القتال الذي قد تستخدمه قوات الدعم
السريع تختلف كليا عن المقاربه العسكريه
للجيش لانه لاحظ في بعض النقاط بعض
البيانات قال بانها انكفات الى داخل
الاحياء هذا يعني الدخول في معركه شوارع
وبالتالي تزداد الامور تعقيدا لكن ما يلفت
الانتباه ما في جمله واحده ما يلفت
الانتباه ان المسؤولين في طرفي الصراع لا
يزال يستخدم اللغه الخشنه تجاه الطرف
الاخر مما يدفع بالتصعيد الى المستوى
الاعلى وليس الى نقطه التقاء وتوافق في
منتصف الطريق
هذه النقطه التي يجب ان يتخوف منها اي
محلل لماذا لانه عمليه الانكفاء الى داخل
الاحياء ندخل الان في عمليه حرب الشوارع
وبالتالي هذا يعني بدايه النهايه للدوله
السودانيه كدوله سودانيه المشكله هنا ان
هذا الصراع هو بين اقطاب او بين اشخاص
وهناك ثقافه لدى الجيش السوداني وامتدت
الى القوات الدعم السريع السودان تاريخيا
منذ 1957 حتى اللحظه التي اتحدث بها 15
محاوله انقلاب اي بمعنى اخر ثقافه الضابط
السوداني لديه نزوع نحو التمكن السياسي
وليس الانحصار داخل الزي العسكري وان يقوم
بمهمته كضابط او جنرال مسؤوليه الحفاظ على
امن الوطن لا هناك 14 محاوله انقلاب منها
اربع محاولات خلال الثلاث سنوات الماضيه
معنى اتحدث ما بين انقلاب وانقلاب الفاشل
يضاف الى ذلك ان حتى العسكريين في التاريخ
السوداني كما هو في التاريخ العربي يعني
هم نقاط سوداء وليست مشرقه يعني اقول
عندما نتحدث عن الانقلاب الاول في 57 او
58 ابراهيم عبود او ثم النميري والفلاشه
ثم نتحدث عن ما بعده البشير ثم نتحدث عن
ما جرى بعد البشير تبقى نقطه ومضيئه وحيده
في التاريخ في السجل السوداني هو سوار
الذهب عندما جمع كافه الاطياف بلغه
العصارمه واعطاهم مهله 12 شهر فقط للاعداد
للانتقال السياسي هذه النقطه الوحيده
للتاريخ لتاريخ للضباط السودانيين
وبالتالي هناك نزوع نحو التمكن السياسي من
قبل العسكريين وهذا للمشكله هي هي التي
دمرت السودان نقطه اخيره تفضل حتى حتى
المجلس الرئاسي منقسم على ذاته هناك
الصقور والحمائم داخل المجلس السيادي
البرهان يعتبر من صف الحمائم الذي حاول ان
يستوعب الاطار الزمني المقدم عشر اعوام من
قبل حمدتي وجماعته لاكمال الاندماج بينما
الكباش وغيره الذي يمثلون الصقور كانوا
ينظروا ان اي اطار جمالي فظفار سيفضي الى
تمكن حملتي والدعم السريع والسيطره على
مستقبل السودان هنا بدات المشاكل تبدا منذ
تقريبا عشره ايام واثبت الى ما افضت اليه
سيد فايز عندما اشرت الى طبعا بانتظار ان
تتضح الصوره الميدانيه بشكل اكبر لفهم ما
يجري داخل العاصمه تحديدا جاء قرار حل
قوات الدعم السريع
ويعني اذا صح التعبير
قرار التخلص منها عسكريا والحسم العسكري
بعد وصفها
بالقوات المتمرده او الميليشيا المتمرده
الان بعد ذلك هل يمكن الحديث عن وسطات هل
بامكان الجيش بعد هذا القرار ان يدخل في
تسويه مع الدعم السريع
عليه ان يدخل اذا اراد انهاء الازمه عليه
ان يدخل لا يعني اصدار هذا القرار بان
بعدم شرعيه يعني هو سحب بساط الشرعيه من
تحت قوات الدعم السريع ولكن السؤال هل
يستطيع هل يستطيع ان يترجم هذا القرار على
ارض الواقع دون الاضرار بكيمونه وامن
الدوله لا اعتقد ذلك يضاف الى هذا
الان قوات الدعم السريع لها امتدادها
الداخلي ولها امتدادها الخارجي لدها لدي
الامتداد الداخلي مع الجبهه الوطنيه ومعه
جماعه التغيير ولها امتدادها خارج حدود
السودان مع